des confitures et des glaces de sorbet
comme ça soit en confiture des confiture
de fraises comme d'habitude quand on
parle de fraises chacun a sa recette
Sucré et légèrement acidulée elles font
le bonheur des grands et des petits à
l'arrivée des beaux jours aux fermes de
Gally de Saint-Cyr-l'École c'est à la
main que les visiteurs récoltent leurs
fruits j'adore la forme de Galilée la
cueillette c'est hyper agréable donc en
plus il fait beau donc il faut profiter
si le principe de la ferme de Gally
permet aux gens de regarder ce que c'est
que la nature ça leur arrivera de penser
que le lait ne se trouve Cambridge et
non pas au pied de la vache que les
produits sont frais puisque on va les
faire les confitures tout de suite on
prend les bien mûrs bon on sait ce qu'on
fait on sait ce qu'on pense
avec plus de 60 hectares les fermes de
Gally font office de potager géants
brouette et sécateur à la main les
visiteurs viennent cueillir fruits
légumes et fleurs en fonction des
saisons cette année le temps clément a
permis une bonne production de fraises
elles ont été plantées à la fin du mois
de janvier il y a une vraie attente de
nos clients qui ont pas la chance de
d'avoir un jardin et pouvoir cultiver
leurs fraises mais qui veulent manger
des produits de saison des produits en
circuit court et des produits qu'ils ont
cueillis attrapés par la par la pédonie
par la queue et puis vous ramassez-la en
fraise comme ça on a l'habitude de
classer les fraises en deux familles les
fraises dites de saison qui sont en
pleine production maintenant qui vont
donner toute leur production de fruits
en quelques semaines et puis de la
fraise dites remontante qui commence à
donner maintenant et elles vont donner
des fruits jusqu'au mois d'octobre pour
les plus gourmands groseilles myrtilles
ou encore grillades pourront venir
agrémenter vos salades de fruits et pour
donner des couleurs à votre table
les listes rouges ou dorés sont
également en fleurs